what if you were bitten by one million  ticks  as one million ticks latched onto your  body and began to suck your blood  you'd begin to feel light-headed and  nauseous from the blood loss  this blood loss could eventually kill  you  they'd need to feed on you for hours for  that to happen but they're not something  you can just easily brush off instead it  requires a precise extraction to get  them out of you  luckily if you can remove them fast  enough you would survive  but if you leave just a single tick on  your body the consequences could be  devastating ticks can give you plenty of  other health problems including lyme  disease this tick-borne illness would  make you incredibly fatigued and could  lead to joint pain and heart issues and  you might end up bedridden from just a  single tick bite so have you ever asked  yourself